[Music]
NBA tip-off hotline presented by
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NBA used the
promo code Patrick making a five dollar
bet this week get 200 if your team wins
Johnny avello is back with us the
director of DraftKings Sportsbook
operations and DraftKings expanding its
platform the cross-section of sports
culture bringing together the lifestyle
of NBA action the excitement of sports
betting the NBA season customers can
sign up
uh bet five dollars uh get 200 instantly
on any team if they win money line
Johnny good to talk to you again give me
where the money is going right now that
might surprise our audience
well uh yeah there's a couple of bets
out there that are kind of different uh
that I didn't expect this year I know
the Pelicans are going to have a
much better team and you know might
contend in that division but they've
taken 70 percent of the money in that
Southwest Division and that's you know
we're talking about a Grizzly team and a
MAV team that are expected to win you
know close to 50 games or more so uh
that was like a surprise for me now we
since we've opened up down in uh
Louisiana we've seen quite a bit of
action but you know Louisiana itself
shouldn't push that team to be you know
the most money bet so obviously it's
coming from other locations also what
other surprises have you seen Trends so
far pre-season uh betting four betting
against prop bets anything interesting
that jumps out
uh Mike Malone and the Nuggets is 14-1
uh leads all candidates money waged for
coach of the year
um a little bit of a surprise there uh
but uh you know regular season wins
we've got 76 or this is the one then
that's you know 76ers uh 50 and a half
wins 98 of the money is on the over
there is they're just uh 76er fans are
expecting a huge Year from this team
okay but how does Vegas counteract that
so they don't get crushed if it happens
to be you know the Sixers going over 50
and a half we don't uh can we go ahead
and get crushed that's what we did yeah
no bookmakers have to take their lumps
and now you know that's one bet if we
lose that hopefully there's a couple
others will win but yeah you know you
move a little bit and then uh you know
if if we feel feel that the price is
fair we just hold that mvp can the Joker
go back to back would have uh what are
the odds
back to back to back uh yeah nine nine
to one
um you know that's a that's a very fair
price for a guy that's a super Contender
but uh you know they're just they're
looking at other areas this year so uh
you know bye
is uh like four plus four and a half to
one uh to Greeks uh six to one Joel
embiid six and a half to one Kevin
Durant eight to one all those guys are
ahead of him so uh yeah they're not not
getting much love on the money so far
any money coming out on the Lakers over
win total
no I don't think there's Believers out
that they're in the Lakers
um you know when we what we saw last
night was a team that uh is has great
players LeBron of course but I don't
know if they have those you know outer
lying players to get him there so this
is one of the higher prices that I've
seen on the Lakers in quite a few years
they're always the chalk or at least
second choice and this year they're
they're a high price so there's just not
a lot of believe the belief in the Laker
team more belief in the Brooklyn Nets
yes and no
um the Nets have the components uh they
certainly had the team to get there
they're another team though that we've
had uh you know tons of money on in the
past is one of the favorites they're
just it's a team that uh I don't I don't
know if the fan base believes in them
the teams that are certainly taken a lot
of money are the Celtics and bucks and
you know those teams that look like
contenders
um but the two teams and you mentioned
them the Nets and the Lakers just used
to be our favorites and just not
happening this year Johnny good to talk
to you as always good luck this season
hey thank you we really appreciate it
johnnyvello the director of DraftKings
sports book operations and uh our
friends NBA tip-off hotline presented by
DraftKings Sportsbook official sports
betting partner at the NBA use the promo
code Patrick make any five dollar bet
this week get 200 if your team wins